Pues la verdad que en Colombia esto has
tenido consecuencias tenebrosas porque
organismos de inteligencia incluso
organismos del propio poder ejecutivo
practicaron durante décadas
estos métodos de infiltración de
intercepciones telefónicas pero
consecuencias fatales para ser
persecución de personas opuestas a los
intereses de la política en ese momento
y también pues se ha llegado a
interceptar a la corte constitucional
los organismos judiciales a los fiscales
es decir aquí ha sido una práctica ha
sido un instrumento de guerra por eso es
tan repudiado y es tan sensible de modo
que un hecho que ha sido denunciado y
que está asociado a un acontecimiento
menor desde el punto de vista Pues de
sus implicaciones de daño o de las
cuantías que están en juego sin embargo
se convierte en un escándalo nacional
hay una gran sensibilidad democrática en
Colombia en este momento y sobre todo
cuando hay un gobierno de cambio que
promete
un estilo y una y unos mensajes
democráticos muy distintos a lo que ha
sido parte de la historia de Colombia